hello everybody and welcome to yet
another
python mathematics and finance
indicators tutorial video in this video
in the next couple of videos we're going
to be discussing the ease of movement
indicator
commonly denoted as a emv not to be
confused with the dmv where there is
certainly no ease of movement
the ease of movement indicator is a
volume based oscillator
as the name suggests the idea is to
measure how easily
the price can move in a direction
although i would really
more so consider this a uh
closer to like overbought and oversold
indicator to be honest but
it is directionally based it's based on
volume and it's based on the price
movement so it does really mean
ease of movement but i'm not really sure
that it
it is exactly accurate in its intention
anyway it is directionally based and
will oscillate around a zero line
calculation of ease of movements a
fairly simple calculation it's going to
be the high plus the low divided by two
so that gets you like your price
minus the previous high plus the
previously divided by two
so what was the change in price divided
by
the total like bar just that volume for
that one day right
divided by the high minus the low
obviously ph as i said was previous high
pl previous low
volume you can divide it by pretty much
anything you want you could divide it by
15 if you really really wanted
uh usually you're going to see 1 million
or even 100 million being used it's
basically just trying to get that volume
number down a little bit so
anyway that's the purpose but no matter
what you do it by it won't it doesn't
really matter
but it does kind of matter um if you're
trying to compare two companies so if
you were to compare them
you would either you'd want to normalize
this line either with percent change or
make this volume divided by something
some measure of the volume
you'd want to make it more of like a
divided by some
factor of that total volume something
like that to normalize the two lines but
just keep that in mind
so let's go ahead and look at a couple
examples now of this so let me bring up
our charting application here
whoops so here's our charting
application we'll go ahead and plot out
ebay
and so here's our ebay indicator here
with the emv
of 14. if you can see we drew the zero
line let me go ahead and fit this to our
window
so as you can see uh as it's moving down
quite quickly the ease of movement to
move down
is only increasing and then as we go up
it increases again as well and down and
up and down and up
a bunch of times there's a couple of
interesting ones
like over a long period if you look at a
company like apple for example
this is how it will defer a lot from
like your typical rsi and it's going to
do something like
this because it's normalized across
the entire thing right so so only until
real recently like the ease of movement
has been you know pretty
stable compared to the recent stuff and
it's just kind of
flirted around then it really went crazy
and
it's not to say that it didn't really
move it's just more of like a charting
issue where you can see um you know here
it looks like almost like it didn't move
at all but if we
zoom in like let's say we want to zoom
in just this point here
and let's uh let's do this
that's good enough i suppose and we just
you just have to understand that this
line is fluctuating a lot less
and this is a really good example of um
showing you guys the change in
in the actual trade volume for even
apple right
and like right here you know you've got
a lot of volume not too much movement
the price has been this way and then as
we get over here the prices have changed
quite a bit and there's a lot of
movement so this stuff like dwarfs
this stuff over here um another decent
one to do
would be like morgan stanley i think is
recently giving us a flat line
so there's a couple of examples how it
will actually indeed defer
from uh like the rsi because the rsi is
is almost normalized no matter what the
price and volume is right
it's always going to be wiggling around
and going crazy and it kind of like
resets itself every now and then whereas
like this line isn't going to reset
itself it's going to be
everything is plotted based on the same
parameters so
um anyway that's just kind of like an
example of where this indicator can go
kind of strange
but again you can kind of zoom in just
on like that one
you know section and now you're starting
to see some movement again
so anyway that is our emv or ease of
movement indicator
in the next video i'll be showing you
guys how to calculate it within python
and then in the video after that we'll
actually be plotting it in python's
matplotlib so
as always thanks for watching